في سوريا منطقه دير الزور التي تسيطر
عليها فصائل مواليه لايران في مرمى ضربات
مجددا ضربه جديده نفذتها طائره مسيره ادت
الى مقتل اربعه اشخاص حسبما اعلن المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان فيما اوضح مدير
المرصد رامي عبد الرحمن للعربيه ان الضربه
تستهدفت مستودعا للصواريخ الايرانيه
وشاحنه محمله بالسلاح مضيفا ان الحادث
يؤكد مجددا ان الشاحنات التي تدخل عبر
الحدود العراقيه الى سوريا تهرب اسلحه
للمليشيات الايرانيه تحت غطاء المواد
الغذائيه وغيرها الى ذلك اكد المرصد انه
لا صحه بان انفجار دير الزور ناجمون عن
لغم ارضي نظرا لحجم الدمار الهائل الذي
شوهد في المكان
[تصفيق]
علاقاتنا متشابكه بين النظام الاسد والامم
المتحده كشفت عنه تقرير كشف عنه تقرير
لفرنس التقرير تحدث عن كيفيه استخدام
النظام السوري لظروف شعبه القاسيه على
حساب مصالحه الشخصيه في غمره علاقات مع
الامم المتحده انتجت فشلا ذريعا في ايصال
المساعدات للمتضررين لا سيما في شمالي
البلاد تقرير الصحيفه كشف ايضا ان بطء
وصول المساعدات الى مناطق المعارضه
الفقيره في سوريا بعد الزلزال يؤكد كيف
يستخدم
النظام المساعدات الانسانيه